yeah welcome to this video playing five
minutes against Grandmaster Impaler
impaler's doesn't sound too nice chess
lessons via skype an English French
espanol and Russian interesting if quite
some song language so available maybe
someone can guess who this is also very
high rated to 6 20's still an enormous
rating in the five-minute pool okay we
gotta declined Benko empty place with
night a six and night eggs before I
always considered this to be excellent
for what but ok and so it's not that i
know it too well ok prepare you five
people play 86 now to just develop i
thought that right would would be
alright in this kind of position as the
night on before it's not a bad piece of
course but it's also not doing so much
if I if this is interesting
if i take my Bishop f4 now this is a
typical sometimes you can even sacrifice
the deep bone but I don't want to allow
this closed centers also looks wrong I'd
want to put pressure on d6 sometimes you
can just allow allow this pawn to be
taken but I'm not sure in this position
as he doesn't have a bit pawn to protect
c5 this means them I could add take on
d6 and I don't see 5 so what is this I
just continue developing with 90 80
covered d6 but his position is all
clogged up now and 36 looks weak looks
excellent for white the kind of the kind
of position you would like to heaven in
a serious tournament game against
someone with 2,600 yeah this is a blacks
idea using the the dark squares
just increasing the pressure here
might be five as a possibility tried to
win a pond yeah just as I mentioned yeah
I can take d 6 but I don't want to it
gives up lots of my pressure on the
position if i take their exchanging the
excellent f4 bishop against the silly
e89 i want to i'd like to improve my
position this is more important
and yeah how to how to do that but
should be five he prevented the night be
five I mean he prevented
and now i'm not sure i can maybe play
this getting this out of 90 force with
tempo and maybe threatening to take on
d6 one point why I wouldn't want to take
us was always nite nite 2d for taking
you to and I'd like to take here ok yeah
i thought i would would capture play 92
but it's probably not so great yeah okay
i need to do this anyway I'd like to
play before also maybe before before but
Queen f6 young ok that's something i can
try to prepare with rupee one maybe
before
before
hmm
I can go here prepare this cannot go pee
should be five I just take it no before
he can take see for what I have be takes
you five is always in the pin on the
default the queen is some service is a
problem opposed to this yeah I'd got a
little time this is the most serious
issue here position is it's just just
okay not quite sure how much
advantageous is if it is already very
serious or just somewhat better for
white but I have little time
ok Knight c3 to d5 probably
yeah if i take its 95 do I want to take
it i'll wait i can just take g6 sir what
is the point can just take this
no even is the exchange here sir is the
problem so this is sound very nice
position
can if I take and play C 6 or c6
immediately
not one hundred percent sure if this is
winning but I want to play it in a
simple way to because I'm so done on
time
yeah it's not the best way so leave it
at least I'm able to make a couple of
moves quickly
check-check
check can I'm morning check check
check check check
black reason yeah this was a nice nice
one it takes or whatever who's the king
I have to check out and promote yeah
this was a very nice very nice game I
like it maybe I sport some of the
advantage at at one point but this looks
really really nice for what I just have
lots of pressure rook a 6am so good move
by the computer okay but i think i just
i keeped advantage yeah if i ever this
was an idea this wasn't wasn't bad i
think i'm just i just keep keep a good
position of course you cannot expect to
make the absolutely best moves all the
time but as long as you keep the
advantage i know we should be six hours
good that i spotted that it really it
it's really immediately great and here
there are there multiple ways to do it
yeah this isn't the best move but i
wanted to to simplify so that that i can
make move quickly here with the with the
little time on the clock and he
blundered f5 late on the scan this
helped a lot of course this is no really
winning yeah probably was before but
check this you can you can even manage
with very little time check
yeah I could have just a drug h80i yes
you get but okay I saw this one and it's
it's winning so quite nice you don't
beat to see two to six players here so
often okay thanks for watching